everybody knows the Appalachian Trail
and lots of people know that the cific
Crest Trail and Continental Divide Trail
lesser known equally spectacular is the
Colorado Trail it runs for four hundred
and eighty-three miles from Denver to
Durango and I'm outside Durango right
now at the western end it's the highest
part of the state the San Juan Mountains
and some say the most beautiful
it takes about 40 days to hike the
Colorado trail from end to end and most
people start in Denver at the relatively
low elevation of 5,000 feet but the
majority of the trail is above 10,000
feet and up here in the San Juans the
high point is over 13,000 300 that means
you learned pretty quickly what they say
about Colorado is true you can get all
four seasons in one day
the Colorado Trail overlaps the
Continental Divide tree all for about
200 miles that means you could stay on
the Colorado trail and go as far as
Denver or Durango or you can stay on the
Continental Divide Trail and go as far
as Mexico or Canada to cover all four
hundred and some miles it's gonna take
you about 40 days
but you can be sure no matter what
choice you make the scenery will be
breathtaking and the adventure you'll
never forget